this is the universe
and this little dot here is the earth
and this is a big bounce coming up
and it's about to squash our planet
next how long would we have
until the earth got crushed into
nothingness
what would we observe from down here
and what would happen next
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if the universe was bouncing
it's generally accepted that the
universe emerged from one single point
of infinite density and then rapidly
expanded
in what we call the big bang but
when it happened nobody was around to
see it for themselves
so here comes a new theory what if
it all didn't start with the big bang
13.8 billion years ago
what if instead the universe had no
beginning
and no end but was expanding and
contracting back
over and over again the cyclic universe
involves a series of big bounces where
the universe acts like an enormous
cosmic lung
inhaling and exhaling a giant breath
with
every bounce basically you've got
nothing to worry about
because the cyclic universe expands for
several billion years and then contracts
for billions of years on a scale of a
human lifespan
this timeline is just not developing
fast enough to affect you in any way
but we here at what if like to add some
spice to our stories
in this case we'll speed things up and
have the universe go through its
bouncing cycle
almost every day and
the next bouncing event is scheduled for
tomorrow
you'd start the day with some worrisome
news from astrophysicists
the stars and galaxies that normally
move
slowly away from each other would now be
moving
toward one another and fast
[Music]
every planet star and every galaxy on
the edge of the universe would be
rushing towards its center
breaking the cosmic light speed limit
black holes would be colliding with
other black holes
they'd be sending huge amounts of cosmic
radiation in
all directions and growing into even
bigger black holes
no planet in the universe would have a
stable orbit anymore
they'd go flying across the galaxy to
meet up at the cosmic
downtown at this point
things would get quite messy on our
planet
and you wouldn't be able to do a thing
to stop it
so just sit back and watch the world end
as the universe continued to collapse in
on itself
its temperature would rapidly become
hotter
the superheated temperatures would
evaporate our oceans
our planet and even our atoms everything
that
ever existed would be wiped out
finally when the universe contracted to
its densest point
it would become a super hot dense mix of
matter
it would slow down for a moment and then
suddenly
start expanding again
a new bouncing cycle would begin a
totally new universe
would emerge new universe
old rules from hot cosmic dust
gravity would form new planets new stars
and
new galaxies and then new
life forms would emerge on these new
worlds
this new universe would expand until it
reaches its limit
and then it would go back to becoming a
dense hot
ball of matter the cycle would repeat
and again and again but
we would be too long gone to know about
it
well that turned out a bit dark
but hey the universe is only 13.8
billion years old
we've got a few billion more until the
contraction
will begin and honestly
it's quite a deep topic to dive into
we've got
more questions and there's no one better
to ask them to than
the very person who developed this
cyclic model of the universe
on what if discussed we talked to dr
anna eosh
a theoretical physicist at the max
planck institute for gravitational
physics
check it out to learn more about the big
bounce and
how dark matter fits into it
[Music]
you